j moins 3 avant la fin de la trêve
hivernale lundi une mesure adoptée après
l'hiver 54 et les appels du pied de
l'abbé pierre ce texte permet au
locataire de ne pas être expulsées de
leur logement même en cas d'impayé la
fin de cette période survient
généralement au printemps mais elle a
été un des cas les sept années au 31 mai
et crise sanitaire oblige à cette
occasion plusieurs manifestations sont
prévues ce week end notamment dimanche
après-midi à paris à l'appel de
plusieurs associations dans le droit au
logement et le collectif réquisitions
mobilisation également aujourd'hui à
grenoble pour dénoncer le mal-logement
et les expulsions on en parle justement
avec raphaël bête militants de
l'association droit au logement de
l'isère bonjour rafale bête merci de
répondre à nos questions ce matin sur
rtl france selon votre association
trente mille ménages sont menacés
d'expulsion au 1er juin soit deux fois
plus d'après le dal qu'avant la crise
sanitaire comment expliquer cette
augmentation
trente mille c'est tout d'abord un
minimum puisque en faites nous part du
principe que l'année dernière il ya eu
très peu d'expulsion du fait de la
prolongation de la trêve hivernale donc
en 2001
donc cette année vont être expulsés les
ménages qui est devaient être expulsés
en 2020 plus les ménages qui doivent
être expulsés en 2021 et à cela il faut
ajouter évidemment tous les toutes les
familles que nous ne connaissons pas
dont la situation s'est fortement
aggravée à cause de la crise sanitaire
du confinement et du ralentissement de
l'économique
donc nous on s'attend vraiment voilà une
année noire sur le front des d'expulsion
donc trente mille c'est un chiffre qui a
été d'ailleurs donnés par la ministre du
logement emmanuelle wargon ça nous
paraît nous un minimum et c'est de toute
façon déjà certains comme véronique
martin secrétaire confédéral cgt demande
je cite un moratoire sur les expulsions
locatives et un apurement des dettes de
noël de loyer vous au droit au logement
qu'est ce que vous demandez au
gouvernement oui tout à fait ce sont
deux mesures d'urgence qui semble tout à
fait opportune
à cela il faut il faut tout de même
revenir sur qu'est-ce qui a précarisé
les ménages en france il ya eu notamment
la baisse des appels dont tout le monde
se souvient des manuels en 2009 puis en
2020 qui a fortement précariser les
les familles les plus faibles donc on
demande évidemment le retour des apl et
la baisse des loyers dans le logement
social comme dans le logement privé qui
va permettre à tout le monde de respirer
et de repartir pour 2022 on va dire sur
un bon pied en tout cas aujourd'hui ce
sont à ce sont des revendications
d'urgence d'extrême urgence
personne ne doit être mise à la rue dans
un contexte de crise sanitaire
dans un contexte de crise sociale ça pas
être une évidence pourtant les
déclarations de la ministre ne semble
pas être suivis des fêtes nous en isère
on a demandé à rencontrer donc les
responsables politiques le préfet de
l'isère les responsables des
collectivités territoriales personne
nous a réussi au milieu on essaie nous
allons appliquer les déclarations de m
nous allons mettre personne à la rue
sans nous sommes évidemment extrêmement
inquiète pour sa propre opinion
aujourd'hui amis qui demande la carte
pour la pour réclamer la fin des
expulsions et le relogement de toutes et
tous
donc c'est quelque chose quand même chez
pour le poids le droit de réquisition et
10 depuis 1945 il
il peut permettre de saisir deux
bâtiments vides enfer d'hébergement
d'urgence pour conduire les familles
sont menacées d'expulsion et pour créer
du logement pas cher c'est beau et c'est
une mesure qui doit être fait en urgence
le collectif réquisitions la paris
notamment à l'initiative tokia 56 et
d'autres organisations a permis
l'hébergement de 2.7 en 1500 personnes
qui étaient à la rue alors qu'on avait
quand même promis fin 2010 8 0 personnel
a eu aujourd'hui on en est bien loin
maintenant l'état doit passer aux actes
et doit réquisitionner et ça c'est
quelque chose que notre association va
évidemment revendiqué dans les
prochaines manifestations de ce week-end
de nombreux petits propriétaires ont
également été impactés par la crise
sanitaire
quand on ne paie pas
leur les loyers et qu'on oblige à garder
les locataires certains insolvable
qu'est ce que vous vous proposez vous
comprenez les difficultés un également
de beaucoup de petits propriétaires avec
qui ont encore des prêts à rembourser
oui bien sûr évidemment bon jeu plutôt
du côté locataires ceux qui vont être
strictement mise à la vue nous on pense
que c'est à l'état de prendre en charge
les dettes des des propriétaires c'est à
l'état de renflouer les caisses si
nécessaire et d'apurer donc donc les
deux des locataires et dans ce cas là
évidemment comme un effort
supplémentaire a encore été fait ces
derniers temps pour pour relancer
l'économie
il ya toujours rien qui a été fait en
direction des ménages et même des petits
pots et il est tout à fait possible de
poursuivre cet effort est de permettre
aux propriétaires de retrouver
l'intégralité du montant de leur loyer
et aux locataires de ne pas se retrouver
en situation de dette abusive et donc de
ne pas faire expulser
voilà c'est ça nous ce qu'on se demande
à l'état d'ailleurs depuis le premier
confirmant un moratoire sur les
expulsions un apurement des dettes et le
retour des apn hong kong puis ces
dernières semaines les faits divers
relatant des occupations illégales de
logements par des squatteurs on a vu
notamment sur notre antenne un reportage
à toulouse
récemment avec toujours au bout du
compte la détresse un des propriétaires
comment satisfaire à la fois les
locataires en difficulté et les honnêtes
propriétaires
encore une fois c'est à l'état de
réquisitionner fois je veux dire des
logements vacants par exemple dans
l'agglomération de grenoble en a dix
sept mille au niveau de la france il ya
trois millions de logements vacants pour
trois cent mille personnes sdf
donc ça fait déjà un logement pour 10
personnes qui sept mille logements
vacants ce sont des logements publics où
ce sont des logements privés
les deux bien des logements sociaux qui
sont d'un commandes des logements privés
qui sont vacants qui ne sont pas remis
en location
et je ne parle pas là des mètres carrés
vite des bureaux qui seront livrés à la
spéculation
en attendant que les prix augmentent
donc les solutions elles existent si
l'état agissait on va dire selon le
droit selon le droit de réquisition
selon la loi appliquée ces cocos loi on
n'arriverait pas à des situations comme
celle là et c'est évident que la crise
du logement frappant de plus en plus
durement les situations d'occupation
illicite vont se perpétuer et les
situations de crise vont s'accentuer et
ça c'est quelque chose qui est du fait
de notre gouvernement et de sa de sa
mauvaise gestion
vous demandez donc plus de moyens et
sert
l'association évoque même un plan
marchall mais comment est-ce qu'on
finance pour ça bah ça s'est passé pagny
aujourd'hui qu'il soit mon mal-être nous
semble que comme l'argent depuis le
premier film en soupe soudain l'argent
magique est apparu on se re re on s'en
est rendu compte
tous ensemble pourtant pour le logement
et pour les ménages les plus en
difficulté on n'a rien pu arriver donc
maintenant il va bien falloir quand même
comprendre que la crise sociale c'est
quelque chose de totalement explosive ça
a déjà été vue que ces dernières années
ça va s'accentuer aujourd'hui si l'état
ne fait rien on se dirige toujours vers
encore plus de précarité et d'explosion
sociale
mais oui il va falloir trouver pour eux
pour financer tout ça merci rafale bête
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes militants de
l'association droit au logement de
l'isère avec une manifestation cet après
midi à grenoble donc